hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück
ich wollte in dieser form etwas ganz
cooles machen uns war wollte ich
versuchen dinosaurier zu erschaffen bamm
bamm bamm
mir wurde ein super kommentar
geschrieben erstmalig die övp endlich
habe dieses blöde gefühl immer wenn ich
mich auf den server bewege ich das ganze
hier
johanna wolff sobald ich mich mal auf
den server bewege ist das ganze einfach
lacht hier
und naja ich muss mal sehen mit das wird
ich habe es übrigens diesen scheidet
drin der ganz cool ist den ich ganz cool
fand also den hier wurde der tag zu
hause aber das ganze war so ein bisschen
blau wenn ich dann wieder eine
fledermaus wurde schon mal ganz kurz auf
das jahr ist es wieder so glaube ich
muss dann wahrscheinlich nicht hin
shader einfach bei diesen hatte ich
daran glaube ich belasse das dann
einfach bei dem hier hat der oder
wandert der war es nicht erstaunlich
das war richtig v 3 preview ganz bei dir
ich hatte mal ganz kurz die ganze
scheiße die ich da einmal hab ich wollte
mich nämlich davor gewonnen sätzen dass
ich die kiste ich auch super tollen weg
gesetzt war klasse sache ich habe
übrigens mir darüber gedanken gemacht
wie es denn wäre wenn ich einfach
überall zäune hätte also quasi keine
wände oder so wie das ganze dann
aussehen würde und ich hab mir gedanken
darüber gemacht und ich bin auf den
schluss gekommen das ist wahrscheinlich
sehr sehr cool wäre wenn ich nur zäune
hätte ich weiß nicht aber irgendwie bin
ich ein fan davon wenn ich irgendwie
alles offen habe sich das holz leder
holz teure halle war für die komischen
holzstämme dann greife ich mal ganz kurz
vor dem tor wieder ein bisschen lauter
der selber so wenig aufnehmen ich nehme
einfach das auch etwas anderes kann ich
sie gar nicht nehmen dann mache ich mit
aus ein paar steaks und daraus machen
wir zäune weil ich denke und das muss ja
gar nicht lange jetzt über hier
überlegen oder so ich denke es wird sehr
sehr cool aussehen wenn ich einfach
alles aus zäunen machen werde
dann ist das ganze nämlich total offen
diese kiste muss dann natürlich noch weg
das ganze dann total offen quasi und ich
muss man nicht dieses blöde glas ding da
voll machen
dadurch hat sich mein raum vielleicht
und ich mein zeug endlich da ist kann
ich ja immer noch weg machen und ich
meine jetzt endlich dies dann halt so
aus dass das ganze halt so ein riesiger
ich sag mal zaun käfig ist und ich denke
das wird ganz cool ich habe auch schon
überlegt ich habe es mir mal in dem
dings gemacht in der folge habe ich euch
ja gezeigt dass man keine grafs länder
setzen kann beziehungsweise dass ich
keine hartz lab auf den boden setzen
kann die dann darüber beispielsweise ein
glas weil das wäre immens cool wenn ich
quasi hier dann half step hinsetzen
könnte hier so ein mal diese blöden
teile hier dass da quasi so ein hartz
tab hinsetzen könnte und darauf ein glas
das ist das glas quasi eine einer halben
blog höher ist es da nicht drüber
springen kann
aber da ja ich muss einfach gucken was
aus dem ganzen haus hier wird wenn es
fertig ist
ich denke aber wir sind auf einem guten
weg das ganze toll zu machen hey komm
zurück und der kommentar wurde mir
zugesendet von mike hayes habe ich auch
schon der letzte woche gesagt hier vorne
muss sich übrigens allgemein noch mal
gucken was denn so wenig daraus machte
dieser dieses ding hier
naja da musste ihm eine statue drauf da
kommt ja die die dings traufe das heißt
ich mache das so
so glückliche kommt auch weg so da kommt
er hier noch der konzern hier damit das
ganze bisschen schöner aussieht und hier
kommt erde hinein und ich brauche zu
fräsen
michael nämlich gesendet bitte macht die
luft und im inventar vor stil eingeben
dass wir schon wieder zu viel aber ich
mache das gleich mal ganz kurz
du musst dir ein alle analysen machen
und dieses grüne ding da ich glaube der
corporate culture lakers ich weiß gar
nicht anneliese dna analyzer soja ja
genau das hat mich ja schon
dafür brauche ich meine feier dafür
brauche ich las und storage class pink 3
ich kriege ich den pick daheim kann ich
ja nicht etwas paaren irgendwie pink
cross rad und boni bei uns habe ich aber
ich froh sind dann glaube ich war halt
nicht aber im coolen rosenfeld ich bin
mir gar nicht sicher ich glaube ich bin
da war nur so komische rote und gelbe
bäume aber die sache ist ja auch so
dinge zu finden die so typisch minecraft
sind es so schwer in diesem motto pack
weil einfach alles hier neu hinzugefügt
wir diesen blauen blumen blau-orange
auch nur eine rote oder vielleicht mehr
weil ich bestimmt verpacken mädels ganz
zu kräften
ein bisschen sand könnte ich mir aber
mitnehmen dann kann ich da so ein paar
neue palm aufbauen oder sind kokosnüsse
mitzunehmen
verschiedene tintenfisch east block
plopp plopp plopp so ein bisschen sand
aus meiner tollen sandfarben ecke ich
verstehe ich warum ich den fackel trägt
nicht einfach anwender aber ich finde
irgendwie immer noch idylle scharl
ostalgisch den sand mit der schaufel
abzubauen
was ich damit meine so hatte ich nämlich
david und ich vorne auch wenn das ganze
so ein bisschen so wirklich ausgesandt
farm sowieso ein bergbau quasi das date
und dem herrn so ich will mir hier hoch
du bist doch irgendwo mal das holz von
denen es glaube ich los weiß ist eklig
und schlamm
diese papiere für erfahrung von zaubern
könnte ich auch mal bald ich schaue
schon die europaletten hut auf hat
urlaub bleiben die community heißt hier
muss doch wohl mal irgendwann eine
verdammte rote so einfach nur eine rote
blume dieses red das ist daran
junior-partner ich dachte charlie
charlie harper
ich dachte wirklich auch so als ich mir
diese weapon box gemacht habe aber ich
hab's ja geschenkt bekommen von max aber
dachte ich wirklich so war okay jetzt
kann er nicht so schwer sein dass man
irgendwie was ist das hier eigentlich
das fenster drin
was kann man hier macht von wieso sind
hier so komische steinkreise deshalb von
besonderer bedeutung weil ich dachte mir
oh ja es kann nicht so schwer sein
irgendwie so einen scheiß zu finden aber
also ein schalt kaktus grün aber es ist
halt wirklich stellt sich echt als
herausforderung dar wenn man einfach
keine wüsten findet was ist das hier
auch dass da muss man glaube ich ein
diamant reinwerfen und alles mein hobby
kraft oder irgendwie so dann wäre ich
aber noch ein bisschen holz tibet format
aber eigentlich brauche ich das ja alles
gar nicht ich habe jetzt zu hause so
viele setzlinge von den teil
mann ich brauche einfach eine rote blüte
eine rote blume dass ich mich so schwer
tue damit die zu finden das ist ja
unglaublich kacke allerdings ich schon
wieder ein bisschen zäh million blüten
vorbeigeflogen du vollidiot lernt doch
mal ein spiel für euch nämlich alle mit
selbstverständlich meint inventars und
welche davon ist passt wieder sehr sehr
toll hier
das war setzling hallo hallo so wo kam
denn die ah da kann ich jetzt direkt ein
paar knochen
wir sind aber unglaublich viele rote
blüten noch geil dass ich dein papa
apples klopp das ist hier doch so ist
dann etwas drin weiß ich noch nicht was
ich noch nicht habe da sind glaube ich
knochen sogar drin
elitär ist das egal
ein bisschen davon noch ein bisschen
nicht einmal kann genug kriegen von den
ganzen scheiß hier für irgendwas ist es
bestimmt zu gebrauchen irgendwann später
ich warte immer noch auf diesen
perfekten kommentar der zehn seiten lang
geht wo mir einfach alles erklärt wird
nimmt das mit dem das nicht mit dass das
unnötig dass es voll wertvoll so was
alles so dass solche kommentare lese ich
gerne und die lese ich auch super oft
aber was ich super selten leider weil
ich so oft da wäre toll aber wir sind
glaube ich auch keine knochen ich habe
zu hause koche ich mir relativ sicher
sein das heißt ich fliege jetzt mal ist
jetzt nach hause ich sehe da hinten
schon das haus was dem caritas
eigentlich wenn wir die kisten da er
wohnte so behaglich hier chris
ok cool ich finde mal ein haus immer
noch einen kurzen am coolsten und ich
weiß immer noch nicht wer sich darum
drauf gebaut hat er erlaubt sich dann so
was
das ist echt scheiße man vor allem hier
so alles hier ist direkt mein haus ihr
vollidioten belle plaine faktischen
schüler bei zehn minuten
ich setze mir noch ein paar zeilen hin
ich glaube ich trenne das hier auch
einfach ab so jetzt erleben wo habe ich
dann habe ich nicht hier ich habe doch
hier ich kann doch das ist doch man habe
ich keine knochen hier müsst die knochen
und haben habe ich dann alles für
knochenmehl ausgegeben so solche pinker
und das glas brauche ich das und zwar
brauche ich jetzt mein glas und die habe
ich sogar inventar oder so supertoll das
heißt jetzt mal pink 3 und umschließt
mit glas haben nun quasi diese acht
anderen glas
ach ich kann mir verschiedene sein wenn
ich vorher dafür brauche ich pink ok ich
hab' ich habe ich diese glas stil frame
glas elcom ist ja egal geht es mit stil
frame glas steve ray player ist wollen
wir uns sonst einfach einfach zwei
cobblestone als ob das alles ist sehr
gut stark so jetzt mache ich so und so
und jetzt habe ich in meknes feier und
jetzt bin ich auch voll bin total folie
wieder ihr euch will ich da nichts
anhaben ich brauche ich ja im inventar
genauso wie den aber im reinpacken ich
bin viel zu voll gepackt mit scheiße
soll es habe ich den stick und jetzt
brauch ich nur noch reisen heißen eisen
habe ich 24
im moment like this fire
ach so ja doch so und ihr doch rum und
wir haben eine dna-analyse und was genau
ich damit mache er falle dann in der
nächsten folge hatte und dieses grüne
ding ja ich glaube der kalk uk
den mache ich mir dann in der nächsten
folge keeway thq schreibt mir mal die
kommentare was ich mir da machen soll
hat er geschrieben damit andere analyzer
machen dann hab ich jetzt hier
dann soll ich mir einen kerl kuwait an
machen dieses grüne ding finde ich aber
nicht du machst die bio fossilien in
denen analyse in melle leiser da habe
ich dann da und zwar real bio fossil
habe ich ja ein dem pack stander rein
wenn du wenn da eine dino dna heraus
kommen was zu dienen das grüne ding
achtung das kann kaputt gehen aber du
kommst die dna wieder die betreiber das
grüne ding mit rom schicken mir ich muss
dieses grüne ding irgendwie hinkriegen
was ist denn dieses grüne ding schreibt
das in die kommentare so viele tipps wie
möglich ich will unbedingt machen wir
sehen zur nächsten folge wieder ich muss
mal kurz runter gehen wer solche fahrer
ich habe versucht mich zu produktiv zu
werden ich bin echt auf eure hilfe
angewiesen
ich hole mir jetzt mein abitur ab
hoffentlich in der schule und da will
ich sagen sehen uns in der nächsten
folge wieder ciao